there was an article in BuzzFeed asking
today whether Joe Biden is too old to
run for president and I think he'll be
77 years old in 2020 I think listen of
course at 77 you're too old to run for
president the life expectancy for men is
I think what 84 or something like that
so you're not you're not too far from
the other if there is if there's a lower
age limit for President but you can't
run for president before you're 35 well
then should there be an upper limit as
well I mean can we cut it off so at some
point maybe 75 or something like that
but it to be for your first term you
can't run for a first term after seven I
think we should least think about that
would you would you feel more
comfortable having say a 32 year old in
the White House or an 82 year old like
who do you think will be more physically
and mentally capable of handling the
most high pressure and important job in
America someone who's 82 or someone was
32 I mean if there's I just think we
should we should think about whether or
not there should be a limit which of
course would cut would require an
amendment to the Constitution which will
never happen but it's a thought anyway
all right so we know that's the media on
the Left are very upset about Trump's
plan for dealing with the illegal
immigrant Caravan and they call it
callous and heartless and racist and so
on and so forth but I would like to turn
this question around for a minute
because we we we have we've heard
liberals criticized Trump's plan for
dealing with the care of it we haven't
really heard their plan so you know what
we what you think we know what you think
we shouldn't do what do you think we
should do 5,000 people show up at the
border all at once
you don't like Trump's plan fine but
what's your plan I mean it's kind of
amazing that so few Democrats are
prominent Limor liberals even as they as
they blast Trump for his way of
addressing the problem they haven't
given us an alternative what would they
have us do what would they have us just
unfurl the red carpet and and let this
unchecked horde of unknown people into
the country just because they showed up
now yeah I know that that's what they
would like to do but should we should at
least require them to come out and say
it if that's actually what they want
to do then come out and say it come out
and say that you think that if a if a
whole group of people five thousand
people show up we should just let them
in or maybe you'll say no well well they
they should be able to claim asylum well
there are problems with that for one
thing if five thousand people from
Central America can claim asylum then
we've really expanded the idea of asylum
to the point where it just is
meaningless these are people looking for
better jobs and better living conditions
which I totally understand I would want
that too if I was in their position but
that's not what Asylum is for also they
were offered asylum in Mexico when they
turned it down so why should we give
them a sign of day if they didn't take
asylum when it was offered then that
would seem to mean that they don't
really want asylum it seems like what
they really are looking for is because
what I'm saying is in their country of
origin if their lives were threatened
which is really what asylum is supposed
to before then they would they should
take asylum from any other country that
would offer it to them if they don't
want assylum in Mexico then that shows
that what they really are after is just
kind of a better way of life which again
in principle I understand that but
that's not Asylum that's just
immigration but more to the point so
fine they they they apply for asylum
they put in their asylum applications
while those applications have to be
processed if we're not going to process
the applications if all they have to do
is just fill it in and then they're good
to go then there's no reason to even
have the application in the first place
then you really are unfurling the red
carpet but so so okay so they're
applying for asylum they have to have an
application the application has to be
processed that takes time what do we do
with them in the meantime we we've been
told that detaining them is some great
evil we can't we can't we can't lock
them in cages that's what we were told
well which they were never locked in
cages that was that was that was not the
policy under the policy under Trump was
not to quote lock them in cages but the
policy has been that we have to detain
them in some way while the application
is prior
says what other option is there do we
just take their application and then let
them go into the interior of the country
on a kind of honor system and say hey
check back check back in in in six weeks
and we'll let you know what's going on
well that's stupid obviously because
again that's that's you may as well just
open up the gates let them in and not
even worry about it that's what you're
gonna do so we do have to detain them
you don't like the way we attendant will
so how do we detain them you want better
detainment facilities you want whole
families together so you want us to
house feed shelter these people in Nice
facilities facilities equipped to take
care of and protect whole families which
is an issue by the way because when
you've got you know it's one thing if
you're gonna if you're gonna put all the
grown men together and that has been the
policy in the past where you've got all
the grown men you're detaining them and
then you've got the children separate
but now if you're putting families
together that means you're gonna have
you're gonna have these facilities where
you've got children and and grown men
and adults all mixed together which
could be a dangerous situation so you
know you've got a protect it's separate
and provide for how are we doing all
this and then what happens when the next
Caravan comes in and the next after that
or the next after that where are we
getting the money and resources and
space and facility to offer this nice
temporary safe housing to entire
families for for you know indefinite
periods of time have you thought about
that it seems like most liberals have
not thought about this all they've
thought about is how terrible and evil
Trump's policy is all right um because
it's Friday I'd like to go to the
mailbag and I had some some a few
interesting questions that were emailed
to me that I wanted to answer and all
right so here we go this first one is
from Nick
it says Matt I've often heard you say
that it's okay for Christians to be
judgmental because we are judging sin
not sinners but what about the petty
judgments of Christians like the people
who are criticizing that Christian
singer you link to on Facebook don't you
think people are driven away from the
church by petty judge
mental Christians who just want to show
off their theological knowledge and
appear pious all the time alright I
think I need to I think this requires
explanation I linked a few days ago to a
performance from a Christian artist
named Lauren Daigle and she performed on
The Ellen Show and I thought that her
performance was was she did a nice job
I'm not really into that kind of music
pop music's not my thing but I thought
it was a nice song she's a talented
artist great singer it's a and she had a
relevant sound actually relevant music
which is which is which is often a
struggle for Christian music it it just
doesn't sound like the kind of stuff
people listen to it doesn't sound
relevant oftentimes Christian music just
sounds outdated and corny and and and
all that but it but this didn't I mean
so it's irrelevant nice sound and the
lyrics were a beautiful expression of
face so I shared it but as Nick is
alluding to here there were a number a
number of people who left comments about
the the song just tearing it apart and
tearing the woman apart they had their
theological critiques of her of her
lyrics they said that well she's not
really preaching the gospel because
she's forgotten to mention this or that
theological point there's actually not
the first time that's happened where
I've I some Christian performers
performed a song that you know is
getting attention and I think it's a
nice song and then and then it's very
common for Christians to respond by
saying well this isn't preaching the
gospel it doesn't mention anything about
atonement it does it doesn't it doesn't
specific well it start starts going you
know offering this kind of theological
ratite of a Christian pop song as if as
if every Christian statement or song or
anything as if all of that must always
mention every essential theological
point it's just ridiculous they think
they couldn't just enjoy a nice song
about faith like they had to find a
reason to complain you've got this this
woman singing in
a nice song about her Christian faith
and that's it
and there had people couldn't just enjoy
they had to find a reason to critique
that and these are the petty and petty
judgments that I think Nick is talking
about and I agree with them I think I
think as Christians were called to stand
up to evil we're called to speak truth
and I think that many times Christians
are labeled as judgmental when in fact
they're just trying to defend the faith
and defend biblical values but there is
also a tendency among certain Christians
and probably among all of us to one
degree or another to be Petty and
pompous and and and to try to show off
our theological knowledge like we think
it makes make us seem like better
Christians if we can find some
theological or exit jet achill reason to
criticize something that to everyone
else appears to be perfectly fine and I
just I think what happens is that
Outsiders see that like they'll look at
for instance the thread under that the
the song that I post on Facebook and
they'll say to themselves I want nothing
to do with these insufferable boring
petty people another example from this
past week would be Halloween
now some Christians celebrate Halloween
okay
some Christians don't celebrate
Halloween and that's fine everyone makes
their own decisions and and I respect it
either way it's perfectly fine now me
and my family we went trick-or-treating
we had a great time my son dressed up as
Saint Michael the Archangel that was his
that was the costume he wanted so it's
not you know we're not where those
families who said well no if you're
gonna go trigger a tree and you have to
dress up as something Christian it'd be
perfectly fine for to be spider-man he
couldn't spider-man but he but he wanted
to be a want to be the Archangel Michael
and it was a nice costume it was a fun
family time but some Christian families
don't like Halloween and they don't
celebrate it which again is totally fine
I respect that but there are also
Christians who don't celebrate Halloween
and they like to announce it to the
world they like to put put on they like
to trumpet
their own piety
and make sure that everybody knows that
there that they don't celebrate which is
kind of in the same vein as the people
who you know giving up something for
Lent and they make sure that everybody
knows that they're giving up something
and what that thing is so it's sort of
in the same vein but I think this is
even worse so there are Christians that
they announce they make sure that they
announce that Halloween is the devil's
holiday it's a pagan holiday a
celebration of evil and they make a big
show of their heroic refusal to allow
their kids to knock on doors for candy
now leaving aside the fact that
Halloween has Christian origins not
pagan and leaving aside the absolutely
absurd idea that families are out
trick-or-treating because they want to
celebrate evil like do you really think
you see all these families out of these
kids dress up as superhero costumes and
girls and you know little girls and
princess costumes and they're going
around with their buckets of the little
pumpkin buckets and and they're getting
candy and having great you think that
these families are looking to celebrate
evil and gore so someone tell me is it
it's a celebration of gore and blood and
violence really is that what you think
that's what these families are intending
to do is celebrate gore blood and
violence I could tell you I don't think
there is there's there are not very many
people who own Halloween save themselves
let's go out and celebrate gore and
blood and violence I think they just
think of it as an excuse to have a good
time
but again it's fine it doesn't bother me
that some people feel that way we could
have that discussion and that's fine but
the issue is pettiness the issue is the
insistence upon trying to make other
people feel bad for not coming to the
same conclusion as you on this small and
irrelevant issue another example tattoos
I have tattoos myself so you know how I
feel about the subject but again it
doesn't bother me that that someone
would disagree there are plenty of
Christians who are people in general who
don't like tattoos perfectly fine it
doesn't offend me doesn't hurt my
feelings completely fine and I can even
have a discussion
a debate about tattoos or you know the
the the prudence of getting tattoos and
I can listen to both sides of it doesn't
hurt my feelings perfectly fine but
still on a semi-regular basis I'll get
emails from Christians telling me what a
sinful worldly fraudulent Christian I am
because of tattoos and then they
proceeded to quote Old Testament verses
to try to prove why my tattoos are
sending me to hell and of course they
take the Old Testament verses out of
context and they take them in a context
that if they're being consistent then
they would then they themselves would
have to make sure to never cut their
beards
they'd have to eat kosher don't don't
wear mixed fibers because the the
tattoos tattoo regulations are in that
same vein so they themselves are
completely cherry-picking
and so it's any tattooed Christian knows
this they because we all deal with this
on occasion
it's petty it's silly it makes the
church look ridiculous and small and
there are so many exam hall is another
example on a few occasions in fact we're
gonna talk about this later on in this
very show but you know I enjoy bourbon
and when I say enjoyed I I I'm not gonna
call myself a connoisseur I'm not nearly
at that level but that's sort of where
I'm heading I enjoy the taste of it I
enjoy the different kinds of Bourbons
and trying them and everything like that
and so on occasion because it's an
interest that I have I'll mention it on
Twitter or something and and you can
always count on having the Christians
come in and not just share their opinion
about but but again just in this petty
kind of way announcing but any Christian
it would dare to drink alcohol is not a
real Christian and is in is in danger of
the fires of hell and then they'll
proceed to explain how they know with
absolute certainty that the wine that is
mentioned all throughout scripture
especially in the New Testament the wine
that was part of Jesus's very first
public miracle they know for a fact that
it was not alcoholic
they absolute fact they're a hundred
percent sure and so on that with with
that
certainty they can declare that any
Christian who would drink alcohol even
though Jesus himself his first miracle
was was was to make alcohol and at the
Last Supper he shared alcohol you know
with his with his possible but they know
there are certain absolutely it could
not have been alcoholic and they know
that because that is their personal
preference and so they take their own
personal preference and they try to
declare that anyone who does not share
that preference is not a real question
that's something we have to look out for
I know I've been guilty of it we've
probably all be guilty of it at certain
points and it's something we really need
to watch out for because that is when as
much as I really don't like the term
judgmental because it is so overused
that is when we earn the term judgmental
because judgmental in the sense that we
look like people who are just just
searching for a chance to cast judgement
and we also look like people who are
going out of our way to alienate others
and make sure they know that they aren't
welcome for the dumbest reasons alright
okay I had a few questions about the
Kanye thing people were asking me what's
what's my opinion now that Kanye has has
his love affair with the right appears
to have ended and he and now he's said
on Twitter this week that he's been used
by people for their political agendas
and then he proceeded to lay out his own
political opinions most of them very
liberal and then he donated to an
extremely liberal socialist candidate in
Chicago gave hundreds of thousand
dollars to that campaign this week so my
take on that I'm not gonna harp on this
I've already I've already made my
opinion clear I said from the very
beginning with this kinda this is look
I'm not gonna get into I told you so's
because I just said we're not supposed
to be petty so I'm not gonna do that but
just as a matter of historical accuracy
I did say from the very beginning that I
really think this Kanye thing is a
publicity stunt on his part
and we as conservatives have a tendency
although usually we try to be rational
and not only that but usually we were
the ones going around announcing that
the opinion the political opinions of
celebrities don't matter and they need
to shut up and stick to the music stick
to the shows whatever they do right
we're the ones usually saying that but
then a celebrity comes along and says
one thing that appears to be even
slightly conservative and we fought trip
all over ourselves in in admiration
we followed the person's feet kissing
their feet because they said one
conservative thing because it appears
that some of us really are you know as
much as we say we don't care about the
opinions of celebrities I think it's
actually Envy we're jealous that the
cool celebrities aren't on our side that
appears to be the case for some of us
because if any celebrity says something
that were you know we fall over
ourselves so I just think we need to we
probably need to slow our roll a little
bit with that and this is a good case
study there was reason to be skeptical
of Kanye's conservative conversion in
the first place and even if it was a
sincere conversion and now he's just
changed his mind it's still it's just
he's just yeah I've got nothing I have
no problem with him personally but I
don't think he ever was a very effective
spokesman for conservative values in the
first place he's free to say what he
wants it's fine but he never made sense
to take this guy and put him on a
pedestal and say yeah see listen to him
he's explaining it all right one more
mailbag question this is from Lindsey
she says hi Matt you often criticize
atheists and atheism but you have you
ever actually researched and listened to
their arguments how can you claim to be
some sort of apologist if you won't even
listen to the other side are you willing
to admit that atheists have any good
arguments at all I think you're a smart
guy but the dismissive way that you
handle atheism really detracts from your
credibility first of all I don't claim
to be an apologist I don't claim to be
anything
I have listened to a theists arguments I
have researched them quite a bit in fact
I think Christopher Hitchens was a
brilliant man
extremely quick-witted and clever so if
you watch any debates with him on
YouTube even though I disagree with
everything you're saying it's just kind
of a joy to watch and to listen to him
because the guys it was an artist and
with the way that he used words and
framed arguments and everything and so
in those arguments that we should take
seriously not just him but sam Harris
Daniel Dennett Michael Shermer Dawkins
Dan Barker Sean Carroll Bart Ehrman
Richard carrier Robert price Oh I've
listened listen or read quite a bit from
all these guys and I fully believe and I
agree that we need to engage with the
other side we have to take their
positions seriously I don't believe in
staying in a bubble and hiding I don't
think we should do that because how how
strong can our faith be how truly can we
really believe if we're too afraid to
listen to the very best arguments from
the very smartest most gifted people on
the other side and we certainly are not
going to be effective defenders of the
faith if we don't even know what the
detractors are actually saying if our if
our impression of the Atheist position
is just what we've gathered from YouTube
comments and and just maybe a few people
we know around us who are atheists and
the discussion we have if that's our if
that's all we know about the Atheist
perspective then we really don't know
anything about it and so therefore we
cannot be effective defenders of the
faith so we I again I fully believe we
need to go and seek out the the smartest
atheist there are plenty of very smart
ones very insightful ones listen to what
they're saying so that so that we can
engage
and we can think and think for ourselves
as well now as for good atheist
arguments I've already and when I say
think for ourselves you know the point
here is it's important as Christians
obviously we want to read and listen to
Christian apologists legitimate ones
real ones and not me but you know listen
to and read Christian apologists
defenders of the faith so we need to
equip ourselves in that way strengthen
ourselves in that way but that I don't
think that can't be the only way that we
encounter the Atheist arguments because
you can encounter them that way you can
go and read a William Lane Craig book
and you can encounter the atheist
arguments and see how he deals with them
which is good but then you're not really
you're not really thinking through the
atheist objections on your own and your
Craig or whoever is giving you the
response and so which is which again is
fine but then you you we also have to go
and listen to what they say listen to
how they frame it so that we can also
think through it ourselves as well now
as far as good a theists arguments I've
already done a show where I engaged with
what I think is the best atheist
argument because it's that it's the
simplest and that is the hiddenness of
God I think this is if not the best one
of the best atheist arguments and the
reason why it's a good argument is
because it kind of says the very fact
that we need to have an argument about
the existence of God seems to indicate
that there is no God that's their
position you know if there was a God
they would say why doesn't he make
himself more plainly apparent to us that
that is a formidable objection and and I
think that in fact when I did that show
on this and I explained how I think
through the fitness of God there were
you know quite a few people who responds
in said well that's not even a problem
God isn't hidden what do you talk about
I hear him in my heart I can pray I have
the Bible he's not hidden at all you
know again when we when we when we
respond to objections that way as
Christians then
it's just they're gonna shut us out
because they're gonna say you know
you're not taking this seriously
yeah you can pray and all that but he is
obviously in a very real sense hidden as
well
you can't look and see him you can't
hear you know you pray you don't you
don't literally hear his voice in your
head at least I don't I've never met a
Christian who did so to act like this is
not a problem at all and it's just not
even a you can't even understand why
anyone would even bring it up
well then again we're just turning
people away when we do that it is a
formidable objection another one is the
problem of suffering any Christian who
scoffs at the problem of suffering as if
it presents no challenge is not a
serious person and not a serious
Christian and I think probably has a
pretty weak faith because if they never
actually even thought about this then
there's how strong can their faith be
the best theologians in the history of
Christianity all of them all the best
ones every single one you can think of
they have all taken this objection
seriously and and and tried to deal with
it and you could spend your whole life
reading Christian apologetics about the
problem of suffering a problem of God's
hiddenness these are big serious issues
now the problem of suffering is only
really a problem it's only a theological
difficulty when it comes to non-human
cause suffering because as for
man-on-man evil and suffering the
theists response is I think obvious and
logical which is freewill God gives us
the ability to choose because only in
choice only in freewill can we really
have love enjoyed compelled love
compelled the joy is impossible or at
least it wouldn't really be love if you
had no choice but to love nope no choice
but to have joy and then then you know
in what sense can we say that it's real
so that deals with I think a lot of the
suffering we see in the world but it
doesn't do much to explain why children
die of cancer and why people drown in
tsunamis and the Christian there isn't
going to be an answer to these
objections in the sense that we're not
going to be able to present some neat
little response that settles the
question once and for all and then we
can all go home happy
think about it anymore there is a
mystery here we have to accept that but
I think we can get ourselves on the road
to understanding we can at least
partially faintly understand these
problems so for the hiddenness of God as
I said before you can go and watch that
show where I talk about this but I think
that part of the answer possibly is that
God remains for us behind the veil out
of you as it were because this is our
time of choosing if he were to burst
through that veil and appear before us
in the sky or something whatever the
atheist say they would want him to do so
he could prove his existence if you were
to he would be perfectly capable of
putting on some awesome celestial
performance that would make it almost
impossible to disbelieve but if he were
to do that then I think it would remove
or seriously hinder our ability to
choose because very few mortal people
accept the absolute most prideful would
be able to look upon God or look upon
whatever he would do to demonstrate
himself undeniably to us very few could
look upon that witness that and do
anything but fall down in fear and awe
and and worship which is an appropriate
response don't get me wrong but then
there's not the possibility of choosing
at that point is basically gone because
we will be so overcome with fear and awe
and and just indescribable feelings that
we can't even imagine that we would not
have the sort of calm reasoned mindset
that we need to actually choose whether
we want to love God or not whether we
want to follow and obey and listen or
not and serve
so for lack of a better term I think
that he gives us space in this life to
actually
so that we're not just cowed and
stupefied before him but able to make a
decision as for the problem of suffering
that's caused by a disease a natural
disaster what we know is that God has
set up the laws of nature and he allows
those laws to work mostly on their own
on their own in the sense that he's not
intervening constantly to circumvent
them though he can and does intervene
sometimes but he's not constantly always
doing it he mostly allows them to work
on their own that's how he set up the
system and I suspect that that has
something to do with what I just said a
moment ago these these two issues I
think are linked that if he was
constantly running in and and you know
putting up his hands to stop the tsunami
from coming or doing all these various
things then again I think it creates an
almost pointless world because now we
don't have that ability to to choose and
decide for ourselves so I could spend
another five hours on these questions
the answers that I just provided
obviously aren't sufficient and even if
I had five hours they still wouldn't be
sufficient but these it's just a few
ideas I wanted to give you in terms of
how we might think through these things
but the point is I do think we need to
think through them and that means
engaging with atheist ideas and
objections and I encourage everyone to
do that okay there are more mailbag
questions I could talk about but theirs
but I'm gonna have to do those later
because there's one other thing I wanted
to mention and this is difficult
difficult for me to say but yesterday
ben shapiro
sent out a tweet that has made me
reconsider my affiliation with The Daily
wire and my affiliation with the planet
Earth in general this is what he said he
said get ready for my hottest take of
the evening
whiskey tastes like turpentine all who
pretend to pretend otherwise may be
safely categorized with those who say
they just love salad then later he said
here for the ratio and you all know I'm
right no sane person prefers whiskey to
a strawberry daiquiri
I'm literally shaking right now I am
actually shaking these looks I'm
literally shaking you think you know
someone and then they say something like
this first let me get let me just say
that I really think it's time to rethink
the first amendment because I'm a fan of
free speech generally but this is not
what the founders had in mind they never
imagined that somebody would use and
abuse their free speech rights to
disseminate this sort of obscenity I
agree about the salad but the idea that
strawberry daiquiris are better than
whiskey is just magette its bigoted you
know it's actually bigoted it's racist
against the Irish for one thing Ben is
coming out as anti Irish and it's
factually incorrect sugary-sweet
alcoholic drinks are repulsive they
taste like a drunk uniform unicorns
vomit is what they taste like
okay whiskey especially bourbon on the
other hand is I think not only delicious
but it's one of the best theological
cases we can make for the existence of
God which is what Benjamin Franklin said
about wine but I think it applies even
more to whiskey now now here's the thing
that ben shapiro doesn't understand I
think apparently almost every good thing
in life as an adult is something that
you have to learn to like something that
the children won't like so I hated beer
I hated wine coffee whiskey the first
time that I had them but as I matured I
learned to love them just like I
remember being four or five years old
and watching football with my dad and
being bored to tears thinking like
what's the point of this but now I
realize that football is man's greatest
invention when I was a child I hated
sleeping going to bed was a travesty now
I just all I want to do is go to bed all
day I I live each moment longing for the
dark embrace of a long and dreamless
sleep when I was a child I I didn't like
going to church now I do when I was a
child I would rather watch cartoons than
the old westerns that my dad would bring
home from Blockbuster now I love old
westerns I could watch Shane beat up the
bad guys with a broken beer bottle and
ride off into the sunset every single
day and never get tired of the
when I was a child I hated olives I
hated Brussels sprouts I hated gravy now
I love olives and Brussels sprouts and
gravy to me is its own food group I
could have it with every meal and on and
on and on one must earn the joys of
adulthood one must work for them and
whiskey is is is one of the greatest
rewards of adulthood and frankly through
his attack on whiskey Ben Shapiro has
come out as anti adult anti man
anti-irish
anti human anti chirrup truth anti
tastebuds
anti joy anti life and I will have to
seriously consider resigning my position
at The Daily wire though I expect even
if I do that that I'll still be paid
regardless because I am the aggrieved
party here and the victim never forget
that all right have a great weekend
everybody and have some whiskey and and
have it have a whiskey and Ben Shapiro's
name this evening I'll talk to you on
Monday
Godspeed